finally a girl is no:1
a girl is eius type of winterfell and
I'm going home
what's up ladies and gentlemen a few
days ago I ran a poll on Twitter and
Facebook where I asked you all to vote
on which video you wanted the most the
first video from the list was released
two days ago about the wall being
breached and the auction that had the
second most votes was Arya Stark so
let's get right into this I got the idea
for this video about a week ago as I was
rewatching some Arya Stark scenes during
her time with the faceless men I
realized something that may be a clue as
to what Arya may be doing during season
seven there was something I noticed that
was overlooked that may prove Arya will
wear water for a face next season as we
all know Arya Stark was in Braavos
training with Jagan Hegar and the wave
so that she could become no one a
faceless man or faceless woman
technically after spending quite some
time there Arya Stark came to the
realization and she accepted the fact
that she will always be Arya Stark she
wasn't ready to let go of the past in
her former life after Arya continued to
fail her training exercises the wife was
sent to kill her and at her face to the
wall but Arya ended up tricking the waif
by luring her into the dark where she
had her sword needle hidden Arya Stark
killed the wife added her face to the
wall then she told Jack and a guard she
was already a stark of Winterfell and
that she was going home an episode or
two later Arya made it back to Westeros
and her first main stop was at the twins
where Walder Frey and Jaime Lannister
were celebrating their victory over the
blackfish Arya was there at the dinner
party in disguise wearing another girl's
face and one thing I want to mention we
aren't sure where she got this face some
people think Arya killed one a water for
a servant and took it but I actually
think Arya took this face from the house
of black and white
I think Arya took this face then put the
waste face in its place not that it
really matters but I just wanted to give
my opinion on that anyways after the
party is over Walder Frey is all alone
in the dining hall which gives Arya the
perfect opportunity to slice his throat
without anyone knowing how it happened
no one's going to know whether it was a
man or a woman that did this to Walder
Frey now that Arya scratched a big name
off her list what is she going to do
next will she go straight home or will
she scratch more names off of her list
what's her next move this is where we
get into Spore
ruler territory so this is your fair
warning spoilers are coming during the
filming of season seven early reports
came out that Game of Thrones was
casting a few more men to play his
phrase most people speculated that Arya
Starks cannon continued to kill more
phrase while she's at the twins which
makes sense you might as well clean
house while you're there hopefully she
waits this shitty house off the map
later on during production of season
seven we got some more news about the
phrase and according to the reports
actor David Bradley was signed on for
season seven David Bradley the actor who
plays water frame now this could mean a
few different things just because he was
hired on for season seven doesn't
actually mean he's going to be doing
anything Walder Frey may be back just to
play as his dead self it could be a
funeral scene or it could be someone
just discovering his body the next
morning just like in season 5 when
Charles dance was hired back one for one
episode we saw Tywin Lannister one last
time in the following season during his
funeral but since Walder Frey is coming
back for at least one episode this could
also mean that Arya Stark is going to be
wearing his face I'll be honest with you
when I first heard the news about water
Frey coming back for Season seven I
didn't really think much of it I figured
he was just going to be playing a dead
body when smokescreen and I actually
made our collab video together that's
exactly what I said but I'm actually
starting to lean the other way and I'll
tell you why personally I would still
bet my money on water Frey just playing
his dead body but after watching a few
scenes I think there's something that I
should point out that leads me to
believe Arya might just wear his face
but I'll be the first to admit this may
be a bit of a stretch but you'd be the
judge first we have to go back to season
5 when Arya killed ser Meryn [ __ ]
Trant
ser Meryn Trant was the man who
allegedly killed Cerio ferrell Arya's
water dancing coach we didn't actually
see him kill sari oh but that's the main
reason that Meryn Trant was put on
aurea's list in the first place
in season 5 Arya got her chance for
revenge once her Meryn Trant visited a
brothel and brothers Aria took a face
from the house of black and white she
infiltrated the brothel where Sir Meryn
Trant was abusing and more than likely
raping underage girls in my opinion this
was one of the most brutal death scenes
I have ever seen not just because of the
way Arya killed him but also because of
how young Arya was at the time
she was still just a girl and she's
viciously attacked him she stabbed him
multiple times she took out both of his
eyes she sucked his mouth full of cloth
to stop him from screaming she stabbed
him in the back what looked like it was
right on the spinal cord and then she
slit his story to finish him off
Aria did not hold back when it came to
killing Meryn [ __ ] Trant she
completely wrecked his face now let's
fast-forward to the end of season six
when Aria killed Walder Frey Walder Frey
helped orchestrate the red wedding in
collaboration with Roose Bolton and
Tywin Lannister the red wedding is
arguably the saddest and most
emotionally charged episodes of the
entire series Robb Stark's wife and
unborn child were stabbed to death by
taking numerous stab wounds to the
abdominal area Robb Stark was shot
multiple times with arrows then Roose
Bolton delivered the final and fatal
blow Catelyn Stark was shot with at
least one arrow then she had her throat
slit not to mention all the other stark
bannermen that were slaughtered as well
they also shot and killed Robb direwolf
you can say five members of House Stark
were murdered at the red wedding
although Arya never met Rob's wife she
was now technically a part of the family
but this isn't even the worst part about
it Arya then witnessed Rob's body being
paraded around with his head cut off and
his direwolf's head in its place this
would be absolutely devastating to
witness then to top it all off they took
Catelyn Stark's body and discarded it in
the river like it was a piece of trash
so you're probably wondering why I just
went over all the terrible things that
happen at the red wedding let me ask you
this what's he vent do you think hurt
Arya the most the red wedding or Syrio
Forel being killed
I'd say the red wedding serie was cool
as [ __ ] but he doesn't compare the
family not even close so what does Arya
do to return the favor to water Frey she
slices his throat and that's it at least
that's all she's done thus far
Arya brutally and viciously murdered sir
Meryn Trant when she was done with him
you couldn't even recognize him anymore
but all she did to water Frey would
slice his throat you could say well she
did kill a few of his sons and baked
them into a pie but after what she did
to Meryn Trant
I was expecting Arya to really go to
our core motor frame this [ __ ] should
have been burned alive or skinned to the
bone but I think she may have only slit
his throat for a reason I now think
that's because she has plans of using
his face to completely decimate the
entire frayed family Oreo would have
never been able to use Meryn trant's
face after what she did to him so she
plans on using water phrase face then
she needs to leave it fairly intact this
is the only logical reason I could think
of the why she didn't butcher Walder
Frey knowing that he deserved much worse
than ser Meryn [ __ ] Trant did so when
I put all this together with the news
that water Frey is coming back for at
least one episode I now think that she
could very well be setting all this up
to use his face to continue to do some
more damage to this piece of [ __ ] of a
family tell me what you think though is
that too much of a stretch to believe
that Arya preserved Walters face because
she wants to wear it or do you think
Meryn Trant did these are the worst
punishment from her list because he
killed Cerio Ferrell give me your
thoughts when it's down below also today
is actually the six month anniversary of
this channel so if y'all don't mind hit
that like button for me one time please
and here's to another six months Cheers
and thank you to everyone who has shown
their support over on patreon I want to
give a big shout-out to my biggest
pledges a dawn of Ice and Fire
Sir Thomas cipher shoulr marine and Kari
thank you very much have a good day
everyone and I'll see you down in the
comment section bye